non non non c'est pas long l'aimiez tu
vas voir on va te le prouver tout de
suite avec cette dixième édition de
rapido qui tourne autour des deux thèmes
majeurs de 7,87 c'est à dire la moto et
le malheur de valeur puisque comme vous
l'avez remarqué nous sommes aujourd'hui
à andrade prête avec mes reportages
plein de reportages des reportages sur
des paint ball
les bandes de motards lee perry dario
argento steve jones et la nouvelle scène
londonienne plus et clips des clips de
joe cocker et demain at plus joe cocker
plus les hot lips non aux mille dhs et
motos raid sur le plateau plus
d'interviews fil rouge et demi les mines
la tête et les jambes de motörhead plus
ont démarré et en première exclusivité
le nouveau clip de jonny cocker unchain
my heart
encore qu'on retrouvera la semaine
prochaine de rapido à l'occasion d'un
reportage que je vous conseille de ne
surtout pas à rater retour en rapide au
numéro 10 avec tout d'abord le jeu sky
rapido qui a gagné coup à cette semaine
s'il te plaît c'est leur marque focus
qui ai gagné une semaine à dublin le
petit veinard et c'est ce qu'il faut
faire don pour participer aux oscars
puy-en-velay il faut faire le 36 il faut
former le prendre si 69 87 2 x 36 69 87
deux fois c'est le numéro de sky rapido
et il faut répondre aux cinq questions
du concours 1
ou alors un ou alors on peut mini télé
on peut mini télé aux 36 15 god
rm oui ça marche à fond on répond à
toutes vos lettres personnellement un
gilles alors qu'elle quel va être le
prix cette semaine et que je te donne
girafe de michael jackson à sa se fait
partie d'une ligne de peluches qui
sortent cette semaine à la broche des
fêtes de noël par le plus grand des
hasards
c'est la ligne des peluches de michael
jackson lisa les les mêmes chez lui
c'est encore le titre américain où aller
michael pitt pourquoi on peut traduire
en français par lé nounours de michael
jackson dit comme ça ça va beaucoup
plaire aux enfants
ou alors le prix cette semaine je te le
donne en mille et bien j'en ai aucune
idée s'est pas moi une harley davidson
non non il me rivière de diamants non
une nuit d'amour avec brigitte les noms
ni d'amour avec moi là encore moins
bookmakers je te dire ce que c'est tiens
toi bien mais je tenais bien oui vous
avez bien oui
c'est un séjour d'une semaine à malte on
continue avec mercy skyrock on continue
avec depeche mode depeche mode qui
arrive à paris d'ici quelques jours ils
seront à bercy beaucoup ce lundi mardi
et mercredi
et c'est un groupe suprêmement
intéressant
absolument mais alors les mille et mille
motoneige qui est notre invité fil rouge
aujourd'hui moteur qui sera tout à
l'heure sur le plateau de rapido pour
jouer quelques morceaux quelques
comptines dont ils ont le secret eh bien
les mythes je te le donne en mille un
débat et n'aime pas du tout les pme ce
n'est pas mal non plus confirmé